hi
so today i wanted to talk about the book
by lisa feldman called how emotions are
made and i wanted to start this as the
first book in my series on a few
neuroscience books that i want to read
this year because i want to get a little
bit wider on my knowledge and
information on neuroscience books so if
you are also interested in reading more
about neuroscience philosophy or
psychology i hope you enjoy these videos
so yeah the first book i want to talk
about is this week is my lisa feldman
and it's called how emotions are made
and i thought it was a really good book
like i gave it four stars i think on
goodreads yeah so in this book i will
dive into five lessons or five ideas i
got from the book so emotions are used
everywhere we teach kids and
psychologists with these standard
emotions autistic people are trained
using these emotions tech companies say
they can read people's emotions nowadays
using complicated ai algorithms and they
are even used during court but years of
research have shown that there are no
such things as universal emotions not in
faces not in bodies and not in the core
circuits of our brain
so the first idea that lisa feldman
delves into a little bit is the lack of
a core fingerprint in of emotions in our
faces bodies and our brains so in
general when we think of emotions we
usually think of certain emotional
stereotypes in our faces so for example
when we're happy we would smile or when
we're angry we would frown but it has
actually been shown that in natural
settings so settings outside people
don't really react like this so when
sportsmen for example are really happy
they sometimes also scrunch their face
or look really angry and sometimes when
someone is really sad they can actually
look quite blank so it has been shown
that there are no such thing as actually
universal emotions in the face so the
next myth she wanted to bust was to see
if there are universal emotions in the
body so for example you can imagine when
your heart is racing and you feel your
chest cramping that could be a sign that
you're really anxious but she actually
gives the example that a lot of women
get misdiagnosed for certain heart
attacks because they are diagnosed with
having an anxiety attack and this just
shows that also the body doesn't really
have a universal signal or universal
fingerprint for certain emotions so
sometimes when someone is getting really
angry their heart rate goes up but for
other people when they get really angry
their heart rate actually drops and the
last myth she wanted to debunk is that
there's such a thing as a universal
signal in the brain and i was actually a
little bit shocked by this because we
learn for example that one of the
centers for fear in the brain is the
amygdala so the amygdala is this tiny
piece or tiny center in your brain that
is usually related to fear or a lot of
studies show that it's related to fear
but she gives this example of two twins
so it's a pair of identical twins who
lost the supposed fear-related parts of
their amygdala both were diagnosed at
the age of 12 have normal intelligence
and have a high school education despite
their identical dna equivalent brain
damage and common environment both as
children and adults twins have very
different profiles regarding fear one of
the trin actually has fear related
deficits and doesn't experience much
regarding fear whereas the other twin
basically has normal responses during
fear so it kind of shows that one of the
twins doesn't have any related responses
to fear and probably her brain networks
don't show up normally as would be for
fear whereas the other twin her brain
kind of compensates for the general fact
that her amygdala is damaged and this
shows that there is in the brain not
really one area that encompasses fear
it's actually different parts of the
brain that work together that create the
experience of feeling fear so lisa
feldman kind of goes into this idea of
the bayesian brain so the bayesian brain
is the fact that our past experience
shapes how we think of our future
experience or that our prior
probabilities are updated by new data
and our prior probabilities is kind of
the biases we have so lisa feldman then
says that our emotion experience is made
up of the things that come from inside
the things that come from outside and
our past experience with certain type of
emotions so for example if you're
feeling your heart race and you're kind
of sweaty your outside experiences that
you have a presentation and you know
from past experience that you get really
excited for presentations you probably
would conclude that your emotion at that
point is excitement and i find this idea
kind of interesting that the emotions
that you feel don't really have a ground
truth but it's more how you from past
experience decide what your emotion is
at that moment and then the third thing
she goes into is that language culture
and emotion are then highly correlated
so she describes this disorder called
alexotymia or emotional blindness and
this is a broad term to describe certain
problems with feeling emotions and it's
also the greek term for no words of
emotions and i thought it was a really
interesting type of symptomology that i
hadn't really heard of before and i
wanna describe a little article that i
read in the new york times about a girl
that experienced this so it's called my
quest for sadness so the girl says the
following i had followed her into the
bathroom and hugged her i had known aunt
lydia for 10 years she had always been
vibrant beautiful and funny but cancer
was stealing her away from us i
understood cognitively then i was sad
but as was typical for me i didn't feel
sad rather i felt matter of fact and i
think this case describes really well
what people usually with this type of
disorder feel so they can recognize
emotions from the outside and they know
that what they are feeling is not
appropriate for what's happening but
still their brain cannot conjure the
emotion of sadness in this case so lisa
feldman goes into the fact that language
and how we view emotion are then highly
correlated and highly linked so if we
don't have certain words for certain
emotions we probably won't recognize
those emotions properly so for example
the difference between jealousy and envy
a lot of us usually mix these up but
they actually describe quite different
emotional experiences dad you shouldn't
be jealous of our poo remember it's all
about the music i'm not jealous i'm
envious jealousy is when you're worried
someone will take what you have envy is
wanting what someone else has what i
feel is envy huh
wow he's right and also something that i
then find really interesting is that in
different languages you have emotions
that are not there in english so for
example in japanese you have the word
natsukashi so that's because she kind of
describes this emotion where you're
really fond of a certain past memory
that has been gone so when you look back
on a certain memory you get matsukashi
for that memory and i think that's an
experience we have in english but we
don't really have to write words for it
another one from dutch that a lot of
people always say is the word rosella
and gazelle is kind of the word cozy but
you feel it when you're with friends or
with family or in a certain situation
you feel really the coziness of being
amongst friends and that's the word and
there's not really a direct translation
to english and the last one i want to
talk about is a word from korean which i
think is such a good word that we don't
have in english and that's the word
and that is kind of this almost physical
feeling that you feel when you're really
frustrated that it's almost suffocating
and usually it's used when someone is
doing something really silly or really
stupid and you're kind of feeling like
ah
and you really feel it in your chest
hair and i think it's so interesting
when you learn certain languages that
you will have emotion concepts for
certain emotions that you cannot express
in english so the thing then that lisa
feldman says is that we are architects
of our own experience
so we are not only a passive observer of
the things we're feeling internally and
then describe them externally but we
actually have an active role in how we
interpret the signals that come from the
outside and come from the inside so if
you interpret something as stress or
something as excitement it's entirely up
to you how you view the world and your
experiences so her last advice then is
that you can actually master your own
emotions if you're a little bit more
aware of it so i will go over some of
the tips that she gives for mastering
your emotions so the first thing she
says is that you need to have a solid
foundation so a solid foundation is
usually for your body it's just a really
boring advice of eating while exercising
and having plenty of sleep the second
one is also to have human touch so for
example seeing a lot of friends spending
more time in good environments with a
lot of plants such as the outside right
and the best tip she gets i think for
having a solid foundation is adopting a
pet i really agree with this a pet is a
really good way to manage your body
budget and the second thing she goes
into is to increase your emotional
intelligence or the words you have for
your emotions so emotional granularity
is kind of how fine grained your
understanding of certain emotional
concepts may it be your own or other
people are and people that have a better
emotional granularity are usually better
at expressing their emotions and also
understanding the emotions of others so
it's quite important to get new emotion
concepts and she says you can do this by
reading books for example which i really
love because usually there's not a good
argument for reading a lot of fiction
books but getting new emotion concepts
is a really good argument for reading
fiction books you can also do it by
watching movies or in general being a
collector of experiences that are not
your own where you're not the main
character and also one tip she gives
which i thought was really funny is to
invent your own emotion words for
certain concepts so if you're feeling
something and there's not a word for it
just to make up your own words which i
think is really interesting if you're
good at that and the last advice she
goes into is mastering your emotions at
the moment so usually it is quite easy
to look back and understand your
emotions but sometimes you're feeling
really angry or really frustrated and
you just want to master your emotions in
that moment so she says to use your body
so like to go outside and exercise or to
change location is one of the best ways
to change the internal and also external
signals for a certain emotion and then
afterwards to journal about it such that
you can re-categorize exactly what you
felt and what you experienced and you
can kind of relearn some of the emotions
so yeah those were all the lessons i
read from the book and i think in
general it was one of the best books
i've read in neuroscience so far so i
really recommend if you're doing
anything with neuroscience to read this
book and also if you're doing something
white psychology i do have to say her
last chapter went a little bit into the
emotions of animals which i don't
necessarily agree with and she also
talks a little bit about consciousness
which i think is not really the place
for in a book like this yeah in general
i super highly recommend and if you want
to read a little bit more in
neuroscience i also made a little video
about that here and otherwise see you
next week with hopefully another book in
neuroscience bye